[Music]
hello my name is ismael yuste and I am a
strategic cloud engineer at google cloud
today we are going to talk about how we started
with google cloud
what is the google cloud platform because
it is nothing more than the outsourcing
of computing services that google
carries  developing in the last 20
years from virtual machines that
start up in seconds and are billed for
use, passing through
container management tools, big data services
to manage petabytes of data or a
complete machine learning platform
that allows you to offer your users what
What do you need?
How do we get started on this
platform? It's easy. We open a
Google Chrome browser and search for Google Cloud.
Basically, we go to cloud dot
google.com. From there,
a first page will appear that allows us to
try the platform for free
.  a bonus of 300
dollars for up to 12 months to
access this bonus we will need two things an
account  from gmail or jim suite and a
credit card
we ask you for this credit card for
security reasons to verify your
identity the registration process is very
simple in this first step it will
ask us for the country of origin
in my case spain and  It will also ask us to
accept the conditions of
service and asks us if we want to be
aware of the news by
email,
as you can see, it informs us of the conditions
of the free trial informing us that
we can access all
Google cloud services and that at the end  the
test either because we have exhausted the
credit or because the 12 months have passed
, we will not be charged on our
card,
inform you that you need the card
for identity verification and for
security reasons,
after this it will request the
customer data in  In our case, we are
a private individual who is going to ask us for our name
and address and after that we are going to be
asked for the payment information, basically
the t  credit card once we have
entered all the data we just have
to click and start the
free trial version the next step will
be to access the console we enter
console cloud dot google.com and we are going to
create a first project as you see
our  project is within an
organization in this case the domain
where we are doing the demos we are
going to create a new project it
will give us a random project name
we can customize it as we want
it will generate a
project identifier that we will see later  It is very
relevant when using the platform and
it will tell us that this project is going to
be associated with a certain
organization.
created we will be able to access it
and we will see here all the information
of the project identification name
project number we see the  billing
the charges that have been made to us and the
resources that we have associated with this
project with this we have seen how
we register on the google
cloud platform and how we have created our first
project I encourage you to start
using the google cloud platform
in cloud dot google.com free
thank you very much
ah